from the playful to the practical to the
cubed to the honored dogs are everywhere
in America
today there are about 70 million dogs in
the United States alone one for every
four people but what is our obsession
with them and how much do we really love
them to find out we travel to see the
love firsthand doggy pampering is a big
business billions of dollars each year
are spent to keep them happy healthy and
well groomed
this is Samson and this is Delilah with
ponytails they're yorkshire terriers and
they were bred to be tiny so they're not
going to be much more than four pounds
patricia young lives in a suburb outside
washington DC they have plenty of
clothes they have almost as many clothes
as I do I can't go anywhere without
somebody stopping us I guess they're
filling my emptiness because I have long
children and there's nobody here
so they're good company for me they have
a robes they come out of the shower in
the bath they have a couple of vest
couple of jackets here they have hats
too they also have boobs which they
don't like wearing the hats or the booth
it's a little cold for that but I think
this is cute this is karate outfit since
it's so cold we'll put these on them
and we're getting ready to go to old
pals and we have to get dressed and they
will have to get in our little bag so
that I can take them to the car to their
car seat
Samson and Delilah aren't just close
horses or dogs they also enjoy the
delights of some R&R at the spa this is
the old town pet resort in arefox County
Virginia the most luxurious largest pet
resort in the probably in the world we
have a truly dedicated staff that loves
animals we hear many customers and dog
owners say you know my dog is so happy
here he doesn't seem to want to go home
because the the dogs can play up to 12
hours a day if they are in day camp and
they get walked three to four times a
day this is our grooming salon and it's
state-of-the-art
and it may be nicer than a lot of your
barber shops here we have Laird ginger
biscuit and totes who are sharing a
rotunda five-star luxury suite these
guys all have television and if you
really miss your dog you can watch your
dog on the internet camera provided here
she just loves it she wants to get in
the water so bad here we have our
hydrotherapy room originally we designed
it with hip dysplasia attic and
geriatric dogs in mind but increasingly
we have a lot of labs and Golden's just
real high
g-dog they all wear lifejackets unless
they're really talented they've been
coming for a long time maybe this seems
indulgent and over luxurious for dog but
you know that that is how Americans are
living and the dog sort of are cheaper
than psychotherapy and as people in our
lives come and go it's comforting to
know we'll always have someone to play
with and call family